initially I was resisting the urge to
make any content dictated by coronavirus
it's a stressful time and in many ways I
think it can help to simply take our
minds off everything with a bit of
escapism but a lot of people started
requesting advice on how to train from
home and of course ideal what to help
out if I can this is something I know a
bit about too and actually feel quite
strongly about the issue I see for a lot
of people trading with body weight is
that they don't know how to increase the
intensity sufficiently to so many people
body weight training means three sets of
ten push-ups but it could be a lot more
than that in fact you can use it to tap
into all kinds of crazy strength gains
that aren't accessible in other ways and
this will lead to immediate growth and
performance I mean you come back
stronger than ever
in this video then I'm gonna share these
strategies so that you can use them to
create a genuine challenge and trigger
an adaptive response with your body
weight training
I'll also be sharing a free pdf that
includes a complete bodyweight routine
which will be available to download from
the website that'll be linked in the
description down below no need to give
an email address or anything like that
just click and download and as a side
note seeing there's a lot of you are
stuck at home and bored looking for
something to read my ebook super
functional training will also be on
heavy discount for the next few weeks
you'll find that in the description
below team so the challenge we have is
training in such a way as to mimic the
intensity you would normally accomplish
with a much heavier weight the first
tool that I want to share is using high
volume training that means training
using extremely high reps of movements
perhaps you're doing three sets of 100
push-up or maybe you're doing five sets
of 20 pull-ups of course because you're
only using very light weight your upper
body in many cases this won't cause a
lot of muscle damage require the
recruitment of the larger twitch muscle
fibers or even create high levels of
mechanical tension in other words you
won't trigger quite the signals
necessary for large growth or strength
gains but the key here is that we're not
only going to be training for a high
table volume we're also going to be
aiming for a high level of continuous
time and attention that means we'll be
aiming to perform extremely high rep
ranges without ever letting the muscles
completely rest this is the method that
has long been used by bodybuilders but
is somewhat contested and debated among
researchers turns out has a lot of merit
though here's what extremely high rep
bodyweight training does for you firstly
aiming for those extremely high rep
ranges will allow you to improve your
work capacity that's something you might
have been neglecting in the gym and it
means that in future your strength won't
be limited by your endurance secondly
continuous time and attention
creates a natural form of occlusion that
means that blood travels to the muscle
and then stays there encouraging the
build-up of more metabolites the signal
more growth by a metabolic stress part
of the reason we experience muscle
fatigue in the first place is that the
build-up of metabolites interferes with
the release of calcium necessary for
contraction thus if you go to failure
you're maximizing that metabolic builder
this then stimulates growth this is why
bodybuilders use a similar strategy to
create non contractile hypertrophy and
it works I've seen countless people have
helped rate and gain massive growth in
their chest
simply by doing high rep push-ups at the
same time this kind of training can
actually create new capillaries that
means you'll be creating more tiny blood
vessels directing blood to the muscle
this can have huge benefits as it means
the muscles will be better served by
hormones and nutrients in future
allowing for improved recovery and
growth an article by Christian Thibodeau
on tea nation recently discussed the
merits of performing a hundred rep leg
presses for this very purpose he
recommended doing this daily he
explained how this helped many figure
athletes with stubborn legs just seem
sudden an impressive growth in the same
article he also explained how golden era
bodybuilders like Tom Platts used a very
similar methods not only did this
building same size in flats as case but
also crazy strength endurance he was
eventually able to perform multiple sets
of 100 reps on the squats with 225
pounds finally there's another reason
that super high rep body weight training
to failure is beneficial it might build
strength by increasing the motor unit
recruitment when we attempt to contract
a muscle against resistance or otherwise
we do say by sending a nerve impulse
from our brain across the neuromuscular
Junction and into the muscle the
strength of the signal partly determined
by the firing rate will then determine
how many of the motor units are called
into action motor units of bundles of
muscle fiber within the muscle the more
that work together the stronger the
contraction but the bigger and the
stronger the motor units the stronger
the signal that is required to push them
past the excitation thresholds and call
them into action so if you only use
light effort then you will only use a
small percentage of the slower twitch
muscle fibers to perform that movement
but as the challenge ramps up you try
harder and the bigger more explosive
motor units get involved this is called
Henneman size principle
training 80% of your one rep max and
above therefore builds more strength by
actually challenging the most powerful
components of the muscle and by
increasing your ability to access your
muscles full strength the amount of
weight moved during the press up is
unlikely to challenge you enough to
require those large twitch muscle fibers
but guess what once you reach the end of
a super long set of push-ups you'll find
that the smaller motor units that you've
been using primarily consisting of slow
twitch muscle fiber begin to fatigue and
drop out this is why you start shaking
now you can give up or you can keep
pushing through when you do that your
nervous system has no choice but to
recruit the larger more explosive motor
units to continue the set after all
that's all that's left this can now
create many of the conditions necessary
for strength games along with developing
a stronger mind muscle connection the
key is to go to the point of isometric
failure that means that you can no
longer complete a full set or even hold
yourself at the toughest point in the
movement without slowly dropping ideally
you'll also eventually isolate as few
muscles as possible meaning that you're
targeting specific areas and that it's
the fatigue in those areas that's
preventing you from completing a
movement rather than just losing the
collective strength necessary across
your body at this point you're now
trying to lift a weight you can no
longer lift the humble push-up has
become an overcoming isometric movement
a tool that was used by the likes of
bruce lee and old-time strong them to
build crazy strength how do you get to
that point will you achieve this by
doing really high rep to an extent we
can go further with the mechanical drop
set go to failure on your push-ups but
then rather than stopping continue
performing more push-ups now on your
knees the core is now being challenged
by less your legs aren't involved
anymore but your pecs shoulders and
triceps are still being challenged with
a slightly lighter weight allowing you
to continue pushing past failure you can
then end with an isometric hold
or even burns these are reps with bare
minimum rep ranges you're still capable
of achieving
so could you build muscle strength and
size using a program simply consisting
of push-ups pull-ups sit-ups and air
squats to failure well yeah but that
would not be optimal still there are
still some limitations to training
purely this way the first is that
performing hundreds of air squats every
day for weeks on end could eventually
get tough on the knees
it shouldn't in theory your knees should
be up to the challenge but there are
more factors that make this likely
that's why it's a good idea to vary the
precise movements between
workouts in order to keep challenging
the body in new ways and provide the
connective tissue with some chance to
recover
take it slow to begin with as you should
do with any new training program and
listen to your body take a break from
specific movements if you notice any
discomfort that is not simply delayed
onset muscle soreness this is an intense
way of training in general so it's
important that you leave enough time to
recover between workouts as well at the
same time introducing a greater variety
of movements will help me to improve
aspects of your strength that are often
overlooked calisthenics has many complex
and challenging movements that challenge
the body in three dimensions and that
works smaller supporting muscle groups
that go overlooked this is an ideal time
to work in the frontal plane and the
transverse plane for instance likewise
you can train for skills like the
planche or the handstand that work your
straight arm strength and your core the
problem is that relying on this type of
training alone won't allow you to
benefit from the muscle fatigue and
fiber recruitment I discussed earlier
this is why many pure calisthenics
skills athletes don't have huge muscular
bodies it strained your inter muscular
coordination and recruitment rather than
intramuscular what we can do here is to
either combine these strategies with the
mechanical drop set which were also
significantly lower the amount of time
taken to each failure or use them at the
start of a workout structuring it like a
reverse pyramid for example you might
start a push workout by performing
one-armed push-ups and pseudo planche
push-ups then move on to the super high
rep push-ups alternatively if you want
to use a mechanical drop set you might
perform as many dips as you can only to
then drop to the ground to continue with
regular push-ups immediately taking no
break in between and treating this as
one long set you'll reach that point of
isometric failure much quicker there's
one thing that's still missing from this
program though explosive starting
strength using plyometrics our program
will also give us the ability to engage
the fast twitch muscle fiber we're going
to failure might not clapping push-ups
jump squats and explosive pull-ups will
all help to add an explosive component
to this training and should go at the
very start of the workouts or straight
after whatever the more complex
calisthenics skills are another option
is to use something I've developed
myself and have recently been
experimenting with bodyweight isometrics
here you put yourself in the position
where you can't perform any reps lying
on the ground with your arms wide apart
for instance and then attempting to push
yourself up anyways this example looks
and feels like you're trying to fly the
earth so I call it the
crusher thanks to commenter roland rush
for suggesting that name as far as the
neurological effect is concerned that
this is like trying to benchpress 110
percent of your one rep max to form this
ballistically and then hold the
contraction for six seconds I won't be
incorporating this into the program as
it's experimental at the moment I stay
tuned for more on this to finish up
we're going to use a yielding isometric
that means moving extremely slowly
through the movement taking a minute to
complete a push-up for example this is
another highly effective way to improve
your mind muscle connection as you exert
just the amount of force you need and as
you listen to the feedback from the
muscles
at each point in the movement so also
you can help you to develop strength at
the weakest point in your range of
motion as you won't be able to rely on
momentum to carry you through there's a
perfect cool-down method as well as an
opportunity to practice some moving
meditation if that's your jam combine
high rep push-ups and really slow
push-ups like this and when you come
back to the bench press in a matter of
weeks or months you'll find you have not
only more explosive strength not only
more muscle endurance but also greater
stability and control this one will be
included in the program and you can also
check out my video on yielding
isometrics for more on how it works
so hope you guys found that useful let
me know if you have any comments or
questions and likewise feel free to
share your favorite home workouts in the
comment section for others to check out
if you did enjoy this video and please
like it and share it around subscribe
the channel all that stuff really helps
me out staying indoors sucks but if it
means sparing even one at-risk person
from the virus then it's more than worth
it and as you can see there's no reason
we can't keep making amazing gains
nevertheless I'm also taking this as the
perfect opportunity to work on some
other neglected aspects of my
self-development and I'm sure I'll be
sharing more of that with you as the
week's go by I hope you're all staying
safe and healthy and most of all keep
punching thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now